hey you did a unit imagine because you
didn't have a deprived childhood but
when you when you make money free fish
when you made money when you make money
you you you bought certain things and
you that stuff that you yeah we're
denied as a child yeah but what did you
buy well I wasn't tonight I wasn't no
any good parent will know any parent in
here if a kid wants a Lego set you get
them in a small one you don't get in the
big one that's like 359 quid so when my
album wins number one I was passing the
Lego store the big Death Star and I went
I'm just a big kid now it isn't just it
isn't just that it's like I went to go
buy my goddaughter a ninja turtle Tori
for her birthday and then I was in the
Ninja Turtles section there was a huge a
ninja turtle truck and I was looking at
the small toy I got for her in the big
truck and I was out getting that for me
you like the kid from big yeah I have a
load of child stuff in my house there's
a roomful of teddy bears this went on a
date and brought a Lego set and made the
Lego set and then left
she was eating your dinner and you were
chatting just kept catching up now it
was no we were chatting you knows about
it she's definitely gonna be watching
this being like yep definitely what did
you make part it's the Caribbean
partnership I hope you gave it to her as
a gift to the end
[Music]